venu tout droit de Jérusalem un trésor
quasiment inédit s'expose à Versailles
en partenariat avec le Conseil Général
des haut de scèes le château accueille
jusqu'au 14 juillet l'exposition trésor
du Saint Sépulcre un trésor constitué de
présents offert par des fidèles et des
pèlerins parmi lesquels les rois
d'Europe et notamment de France les rois
de France ont été toujours des
protecteurs des lieux saints et ont donc
contribué par des présences sombres
à la célébration du culte divin à
Jérusalem l'exposition présente aux
visiteurs un extraordinaire ensemble
d'œuvres d'art accumulé au cours de
l'histoire des pièces d'orfèvrerie ou
des vêtements liturgiques d'exception
sont à découvrir parmi plus de 250
chef-dœuvres inconnu et restauré à cette
occasion parce que ce trésor sans être
véritablement caché parce qu'il y avait
pas volonté de le cacher n'était pas
visible puisqu'il était dans des
sacristies du couvent de Saint Sauveur à
Jérusalem au Saint Sépulcre à Bethléem
euh un peu aussi à Nazareth à in carê
donc dispersé et là ça a été donc
l'occasion de les étudier bien sûr de
les restaurer aussi puisque tous ces
objets ont servi servent encore donc
voir les objets c'est extraordinaire
mais c'est aussi les remettre dans le
contexte et c'est-à-dire expliquer la
fonction des pièces l'exposition se
prolonge la maison de châteaubillant
neuf peintures y sont présentées
complétant ainsi le projet tant
artistique
qu'historique